castle point and rockford health and
well-being strategy reset
physical health workshop from the 9th of
september 2020
facilitated by dawn emerson who is the
relationship manager
at south essex active essex
emerging themes within physical health
levels of child and adult overweight and
obesity
trends in physical activity and
inactivity levels
prevalence of long-term conditions such
as coronary heart disease
stroke diabetes hypertension and
dementia
incidence of vaccinated diseases
hospital
admissions due to falls and hip
fractures in older adults
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
also known as
copd stroke and coronary heart disease
also known as chd
questions to consider as you look at the
data one
what does the data tell us two what do
you think are the key priorities and how
should we
be addressing them three what additional
issues or effects
has covert 19 had on physical health and
how might it paint a different picture
to what we see here
levels of overweight and obesity in
castle point and rochford
just over half of adults in castle point
at 50.5 percent
and rochford at 54.6 percent are meeting
the five a day recommended
intake of fruit and vegetables on a
usual day
a fifth or twenty percent of reception
aged children in rochford
and nearly a quarter or 24 in castle
point are overweight or obese
over a third or thirty five percent of
year six pupils in castle point
and 27 in rochford are overweight or
obese
two-thirds of adults in castle point and
63 percent
of adults in rockford are overweight or
obese
dawn emberson commented on this saying
we are hearing anecdotally that schools
are seeing their pupils return in a very
deconditioned state
even visually they can tell their
obesity levels have risen
harriet pickering also commented saying
as life's pace has picked up
people have neglected their exercise and
health
this data was obtained from public
health england's public health profiles
indicators of physical activity levels
according to data from 2018 to 19
full england active lives adult and
children surveys
less than half of children and young
people in castle point and rochford
are doing an average of 60 minutes or
more activity
every day across the week approximately
a third of children and young people are
inactive this means doing less than 30
minutes a day
59 of adults in castle point and 63
in rockford are classed as active this
means doing 150 minutes
or more activity each week
thirty percent of adults in castle point
and twenty two percent in rockford
are doing less than thirty minutes of
activity each day
participation in the daily mile eight
after
twenty five or thirty two percent of
schools in castle point
and 14 out of 24 or 58
of schools in rochford are taking part
in the daily mile
this is the data as of july 2020
supplied by active essex
comparisons within different age groups
compared to the november 2017-18 survey
the percentage of physically active 16
to 34 year olds
has decreased from 85.9 to 60
in castle point and from 83.4 percent
to 65.5 in rochford
also fewer adults aged 55 to 74
are physically active in castle point
than in rochford
emma colby commented on this saying as
professional people it is more about
keeping people engaged in physical
activity
as the intention always seems to be
there
changes in activity levels since curving
19.
insight from the state of life survey
state of life does not purport to
be strictly representative of the whole
essex population
state of life was an online survey
distributed via social media
designed to gather key insights on
well-being across essex
key findings from the surveys first two
weeks
commencing 13th of april and week
commencing the 20th of april 2020
showed that a higher proportion of essex
residents reported being physically
active
at 59.5 and a lower proportion reported
being physically inactive
at 24 compared to pre-covered 19
baseline levels
which was 47.4 and 29.3
respectively this equates to an increase
in the average number of days doing 30
minutes of physical exercise
from 3.8 days to 4.1 days
however the proportion who reported
being physically
active decreased over the first two
weeks of the survey
from 62.2 week commencing the 13th of
april
to 55.5 percent week commencing the 20th
of april
this data was extracted from the essex
county council's state of life survey
initial highlights report prevalence of
long-term conditions
quality outcome framework also known as
quaff prevalence is the estimated
proportion of all those registered at gp
surgeries
with a diagnosis it tells us how common
certain conditions are in a particular
area
diabetes quaff prevalence for people age
17 plus is given for the castle point
and rockford ccg
area combined prevalence of hypertension
coronary heart disease
stroke and dementia is fairly similar in
carter point and rockford
although hypertension is slightly higher
in castle point
at 18.07 percent than rochford at 16.13
and dementia is slightly higher in
rochford at 1.04
than in castle point at 0.77 percent
the quaff prevalence of all conditions
is higher than the essex and england
averages for each
these figures were obtained from the
jsna 2019 profiles
emergency hospital admissions the number
of emergency hospital admissions due to
hip fractures
stroke and coronary heart disease are
fairly similar in castle point and
rockford
but emergency hospital admission is due
to chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
are much higher in castle point than in
rochford
in castle point there are 102 compared
to 81.6
in rockford the emergency admission
ratio for copd in castle
point is 102 and in rockford is 81.6
the emergency admission ratio for chd in
castle point
is 84.7 and in rockford is 90.5
the emergency admission ratio for hip
fractures in castle point
is 104.5 and in rockford is 101.9
the emergency admission ratio for
strokes in castle point is 102
and in rochford is 105 105.7
these numbers are the standardized
admission ratios
this is defined as the ratio of the
observed number of admissions in an area
to the number expected if the area had
the same age specific rate as england
these figures were obtained from the
gsna 2019 profiles
falls and hit fractures castle point and
rochard had the second and third highest
rates of emergency hospital admissions
due to falls in people aged 65 and over
across essex
the age standardized rate of admissions
is 2362.11 in castle point
and 2258.51 in rockford
by far higher than the rates across
essex at 2059.46
and england at 2170.43
castle point rochford and basildon were
the only districts in essex with a
higher rate than england
the rates of emergency hospital
admissions due to hip fractures among
people aged over 65 years
in castle point at 588.79
and rockford at 607.61
are both lower than the rate across
essex at 611.9
as a whole but higher than england at
577.76
figures quoted our age standardized
rates of emergency hospital admissions
due to falls and hip fractures values
given are per 100 000 population
the 2017-18 data was taken from the
hospital episode
statistics dawn emberson commented on
these figures
saying if we are thinking about
priorities what can we do with this
particular age group
of 65 to 79 to make sure that they're
not having an increase in hospital
admissions by the time that they are 80.
strength and balance work for that age
group could be really important
musculoskeletal health according to the
2019 jsna profiles
39.3 of residents in castle point
and 36.8 in rochford report having a
long-term musculoskeletal problem
these are both higher than the average
for essex at 34.9 percent
and england at 33.5 similarly
15.3 percent of residents in castle
point and 13.4
in rochford report having arthritis or a
long-term joint problem
which are also higher than the figures
for england at twelve point two percent
and essex at twelve point six percent on
the contrary the corporate valence of
patients aged fifty plus with a recorded
diagnosis of osteoporosis in castle
point and rockford
is lower than the national average of
0.62
and the essex average of 0.39 percent
the prevalence in castle point at
0.26 was the lowest level in essex
the prevalence in rockford is 0.29
vaccinatable diseases castle point has
the highest incident rate of measles in
the county with 11.13 per 100 000 people
this is worse an england average of 1.74
per 100 000 people
and the only area class is significantly
worse than england
rochford has the highest incident rate
of mumps in essex
with 3.5 per 100 000 people
this is higher than essex which is 1.1
per
100 000 people this data was taken from
the
2019 jsna profiles emma colby commented
on this saying
the health visitor does assess each
family individually
and they can see if the immunization is
not done and will question the family
it will be interesting to see what
general feedback people are giving
health visitors
parents are challenged so they would be
able to give you a narrative around the
thinking
dawn emerson also commented saying maybe
we start to think about what that means
is that to do with sign posting is it to
do with social media campaigns
is it to do with a lack of understanding
or education around these things in
those areas
if there are opportunities to welcome
parents to face-to-face groups
or social media groups for example to
give information on some of the
medical standpoints can we engage those
groups with any other messaging
other factors to acknowledge are wider
determinants of health and health
inequalities
for example build a natural environment
work
vulnerability income crime
education and skills family and
lifestyle
deprivation data which will be
summarized on the next slide
barriers that may present challenges but
also opportunities
assets within castle point and rockford
and direct and indirect effects of
coveted 19.
dawn emerson commented on this saying it
might allow us to do some much more
targeted work
where some of those underrepresented
groups would be willing to work with us
on something specific that really suits
their needs
levels of deprivation within castle
point according to essex county
council's indices of multiple
deprivation 2019 report
castle point is ranked 4th out of 12 in
the county for overall deprivation
8.7 percent of the total castle point
population
live in the most deprived 20 of areas
of the 10 most deprived lower layer
super
output areas known as lsoas
in castle point nine are located on
canvay
a lower layer super output area is a
geographic area with a population of
around
1500 people
levels of deprivation within rochford
according to essex county councils
indices of multiple deprivation 2019
report
rochford is in the upper 10 of least
deprived lower tier local authorities
nationally
and is ranked as 10th out of 12 in the
county for overall deprivation
over half of the rockford population
live in the 20
least deprived areas nationally this is
significantly higher than the average of
essex which is 25.6 percent
and is the highest level in essex 1.8
of the total population of rochefort
live in the most twenty percent deprived
of areas
richard has no lower layer super output
areas in desire1
the most deprived but has one lsoa
in decile 2.
next steps is there other data you can
share to provide more insight
what other actions are necessary to
tackle the issues identified in terms of
early intervention and prevention
who else needs to be involved we will
meet before the december board meeting
to continue discussion and thinking
and develop the draft narrative around
this priority for the new strategy
in this discussion dawn emerson
commented that the data tells us
where we have some real disparity
between castle point and rockford
emma colby commented saying the data
reflects what we have noticed from our
calls
she also commented saying food banks
were probably quite a good opportunity
to introduce fruit and veg
but there are challenges around that
with storage
harriet pickering commented on this
saying that could be a really good
action if we could make it affordable
for families
where more families will be struggling
financially from covid
getting access to vegetables and that
being available could be a good thing
for all age groups
she also commented saying information
collated from the essex child and family
wellbeing service hubs
health visitors and school nurses might
add real strength to the start well
child and young people focus to bring in
some of that data and enrich the health
and well-being board
the key themes for this discussion are
community spirit and isolation